this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
sign up today at curiositystream.com
real science for just 14.79 to listen to
the first episode of the new season of
the show makers podcast
where sam from wendover productions and
brian from real engineering
interview me about the origins of this
channel and my scientific and creative
background
last year a strange and unexpected sight
off the northern coast of norway
captured the world's attention
a lone beluga whale wearing a tight
harness with the words property of saint
petersburg printed on it
belugas are normally found in icy and
glacial areas
not along this part of the norwegian
coast and certainly not alone
his discovery became even more baffling
when fishermen noticed that he was
tugging on their ropes
and was so tame that they could pet him
while a friendly whale is entertaining
to most of us
he instantly alarmed norwegian officials
experts believed he had likely been
trained to spy for russia
eventually fishermen were able to cut
his harness off
and the whale followed a sailboat to
hammerfest harbor
there he bonded with the locals and was
named valdemir
a play on the norwegian word for whale
vaal
and his supposed leader vladimir putin
an anonymous source reported that he had
indeed escaped from a navy program in
mormonts russia
but despite the speculation russia
denied ownership of him
and no one ever claimed him and valdemir
has thus remained free
and never got in trouble from his
comrades for defecting
we may never know exactly what this
whale was trained to do
or what his exact job title was but his
discovery shines a light on the long
history that marine mammals do
have inside the military in russia yes
but also in the united states
some find the concept amusing some find
it troubling
but for decades militaries have trained
fleets of dolphins
whales and sea lions for intricate and
sometimes covert operations
dolphins in particular have become the
watchdog for the us
navy over the last few decades
protecting military ships and bases from
serious harm
carrying out tasks that no technology
can replicate
why are these animals so valuable to the
military
and why has no man-made technology ever
been able to take their place
[Music]
humans have enlisted animals to help
with their military operations for
centuries
pigeons have been used to carry messages
since around 600 bc
possibly beginning when the persian king
cyrus used them to communicate with
distant parts of his empire
elephants were first used for war in
ancient india around 400 bc
trampling and terrifying enemy soldiers
horses camels dogs all have been
recruited to help in wartime
but all of this was done on land it
wasn't until the 20th century that
militaries began to look to the animal
kingdom for help in their underwater
operations
in the 1960s in the depths of the cold
war
undersea tactics were becoming more and
more important
the nuclear submarine had just been
revolutionized between 1945 and 1960
and the importance of effective sonar
was becoming clear
the us was scrambling to stay on top of
this technological competition with the
soviets
and began to look for inspiration in
unexpected places
thus in 1960 the us began a new kind of
covert operation
the u.s navy marine mammal program
the first research involved hydrodynamic
studies on a pacific white-sided dolphin
seeking to improve torpedo performance
the navy wanted to design
better underwater missiles and dolphins
seemed like the perfect animal to study
to see if they had drag reduction
systems that could be replicated
they also wanted to study the underwater
sonar capabilities of dolphins and
whales
to learn how to design more efficient
methods of detecting objects underwater
however soon after beginning these
studies
scientists realized that these dolphins
weren't just well designed
they were also trainable adaptable and
extremely
intelligent a major milestone was the
discovery that dolphins could work
reliably in the open sea
untethered from their human trainers in
1965
a navy dolphin named tuffy participated
in the sea lab
2 project carrying tools and messages
between the surface and the habitat
60 meters below the surface the true
potential of the navy's dolphins was
starting to become realized
today navy dolphins are primarily
trained in one
important task to locate underwater
objects and with this
they have one quality that makes them
unbeatable
their sonar or echo location as it's
called in the dolphin world
echolocation allows dolphins to see with
sound
after the dolphin takes a breath
pressure from streams of air bubbles
move up the airway from the lungs
this causes two flaps called the phonic
lips to slap together
the clicking vibrations are then
transferred to their bulbous forehead
aptly called their melon the melon is an
organ made up of specialized fats that
help
sound propagate the clicks are organized
into a beam as it travels through the
melon
the sound is then emitted outwards as a
series of high frequency clicks
the clicks have peak energy at
frequencies ranging from 40 to 130
kilohertz
and with levels recorded over 220
decibels
decibels underwater are measured
slightly differently than an air
making this seem extreme but it is still
insanely loud
sound waves travel through water at a
speed of about 1.5 kilometers per second
which is about 4.5 times faster than
sound
traveling through air however high
frequency sounds don't travel
far in water because of their longer
wavelength and greater energy
low frequency sounds travel farther but
because
dolphin clicks are high frequency echo
location is most effective at close
range
once the sound is emitted from the melon
and into the environment
it bounces off an object and returns as
a series of echoes to the dolphin's
mandible
specialized fatty tissues in the jaw
area pick up the sound
and auditory nerves conduct it to the
middle ear and brain
where it creates the picture of the
environment for the dolphin
man-made sonar works in a similar way
but without the fatty forehead tissue
to locate a target submarines for
example use active and passive sonar
active sonar emits pulses of sound waves
that travel through the water
reflect off the target and return to the
ship
by knowing the speed of sound and water
and the time for the sound wave to
travel to the target and back
computers can quickly calculate distance
between the submarine and the target
ships can also use this technology to
map the ridges of the ocean floor
and get a general understanding of what
lies beneath the surface
passive sonar emits no signals instead
it just listens for sounds coming from
external sources
but man-made sonar can easily get
confused if there are competing noises
turbulence in shallow water waves other
ships or even your own ship as you are
trying to use a sonar system
can muddle up the signal this is why
man-made sonar is best suited for low
frequency and long ranges in the open
ocean
usually in the sofar channel around one
kilometer deep
where sound travels best due to the
specific combination of the temperature
and pressure there this is great for
general oceanic surveillance
but what if the thing you desperately
need to find is in
shallow water or buried under mud hidden
out of sight
[Music]
for the navy such a quandary is an
ever-present source of anxiety
lurking beneath the surface and often
beneath the sand
are explosive devices placed there to
damage or destroy
surface ships or submarines they are
deposited and sit idle
until they are triggered by the approach
of or contact with
any vessel during the gulf war
several navy boats were severely damaged
by mines
and in many places they are still
littered along the ocean floor from
conflicts that happened years ago
but finding buried targets on the ocean
floor is a very big challenge for
man-made sonar systems
a large portion of a sound signal
directed downward
strikes the bottom and is reflected or
scattered before
any sound waves can penetrate the bottom
objects in the bottom
such as rocks or non-target junk also
return echoes using any energy that does
manage to penetrate the sea floor
it is almost impossible for current
man-made sonar systems
to distinguish items so small and so
often shrouded by mud
and so for the us navy this is where the
dolphins come in
dolphins have spent the last several
million years evolving in exactly the
type of environment where man-made sonar
struggles
in shallow sometimes murky and turbulent
water
even using their ability to hunt for
prey that is buried beneath the sand
bottlenose dolphins can identify many
characteristics of submerged objects
including size structure shape and even
material composition
they can tell the difference between
aluminum copper and brass targets
or if a target is hollow or solid when a
target is covered in neoprene or buried
in sand
they can discriminate between circles
squares and triangles
a dolphin's ability to discriminate the
size and composition of a target object
may be due to the complex structure of
the echo
and their incredible ability to decipher
it
after a dolphin sends out its
echolocation clicks
there is often a primary echo resulting
from the main reflection off the surface
and a secondary echo due to the smaller
vibrations induced within the target
the presence of these different echoes
produces nulls and peaks in the
frequency
that the dolphin can understand as
differences in the size and composition
of the target
and these evolved mechanisms and
extraordinary
abilities are exactly what the navy has
harnessed in its mark vii mine clearance
system
within the u.s military there are five
marine mammal teams
each trained for a specific type of
mission the five teams are called mark
four five six seven and eight the mark
four
seven and eight teams use dolphins mark
five uses sea lions
and mark six uses both sea lions and
dolphins
these teams can be deployed at 72 hours
notice to conflicts around the world
in 2003 during the iraq war the navy
sent two
dolphins to help with clearing minds in
the murky waters of um casa port
the dolphins helped clear the way for
ships carrying humanitarian aid
the water was so opaque that the divers
likened the search for minds to crawling
around in the mud with your eyes shut
but dolphin sonar worked just fine
dozens of mines were cleared and the
ship's precious cargo of water
food medicine and emergency supplies was
able to be delivered to the struggling
region
here's how an operation like this works
on the way to a minefield a dolphin will
travel by boat with its human handlers
protected by a padded folded mat
once the group arrives the handlers
unfold the mat and the dolphin slides
into the water and begins to search for
a mine
it has been trained to look for
suspicious man-made or
metal objects when the dolphin thinks
it's found one
it will swim back up to the boat to poke
an appropriate signifier such as a ball
with its nose the handlers then give it
a marking device
like a buoy or a special device known as
an acoustic transponder
which the animal leaves in the area it
spotted the mine
the dolphin uses its snout to carry the
device down to the object
this device either floats or produces a
distinct sound that allows human divers
to find it later
the dolphin is then rewarded with verbal
preys and fish
dolphins can similarly be trained to
detect enemy swimmers
and there are rumors that they have also
been trained to attack and
even kill them during the vietnam war
these rumors claimed that dolphins were
used in lethal
swimmer nullification programs with
their beaks fitted with needles to
deliver
fatal injections of carbon dioxide gas
to viet cong divers
the navy of course denies this
some animal advocates claim that the
navy's use of marine mammals is
exploitative and immoral
with the opinion that any form of
captivity for marine mammals is
distressing for them
akin to a prison but those who work
closely with these dolphins see the work
as
important and essential to the safety of
american citizens
and the navy insists its dolphins are
happy and like what they
do and that where they live is not like
a prison at all
it's more like a classroom where
dolphins spend the day working with
trainers and vets
and at night underwater gates open
letting the animals swim and socialize
together in larger areas
they are cared for like fellow crew
members receiving top-notch medical care
when they are sick
and are generally beloved by their human
colleagues
it's impossible to know what the
dolphins are thinking but we all
obviously hope that they are enriched by
and enjoy their work
but in the end the dolphins do work
untethered in the open ocean
in the 2003 iraq mission i just
mentioned
one of the dolphins tacoma disappeared
thought to have gone awol
and our friend from before valdemir
appears to have left his post too
did they get lost chasing some local
marine life
or is it a sign of their unhappiness we
may never know
but what we do know is that in their
service to the us
navy they have cleared minds across the
world
undoubtedly saving countless lives
[Music]
subjects like this that explore the
relationship between militaries and
science are something that both me
and brian at real engineering like to
cover in our videos
but do so with some trepidation on
youtube
unfortunately sometimes certain topics
or words like
war related things can trigger the
algorithm to demonetize our videos
even if the video is strictly
educational
this is why me and several of the top
youtube educational content creators
have started our own streaming platform
called nebula
it's a place where we can express
ourselves completely freely and openly
without worrying about d monetization
real engineering series the logistics of
d-day is a prime example of the content
you can find there
the latest episode is about the
logistics of refueling 55
000 vehicles in the first week of the
invasion of normandy
it was a massive challenge that i
personally had never considered
and is something that was absolutely
crucial to the allies success
nebula also allows us to take our time
producing content
and open so many creative doors because
of this
there is a range of awesome content you
can find there
long form documentaries by creators like
wendover productions
originals from creators like polyphonic
tom scott or mustard
or a new section for original podcasts
the showmakers podcast for example is
made by brian from real engineering and
sam from wendover productions
it's a show where they talk to different
online creators to learn more about
their life and their craft
the latest episode features me so if you
want to hear the origin story of real
science
learn about my background and how i
started working with brian
how i met sam on a semi-disastrous trip
in mexico
and generally hear brian and sam attempt
to host a podcast
then this is the podcast for you and to
make it even better
nebula has partnered with curiosity
stream curiosity stream is a streaming
platform with
thousands of high quality documentaries
about things like history
space technology or nature like this one
called conversations with dolphins
which explores whether or not dolphins
think the same way we do
and if we will ever be able to actually
communicate with them
so if you sign up for curiosity stream
at curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream
and a subscription to nebula for now
just 14.79 a year
26 off the usual price by signing up
you're not just supporting this channel
but all of your favorite educational
content creators
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
see more from me the links to my
instagram twitter and patreon are below
[Music]
you